this fight over the system has really
irritated Tom Hanks Tom Hanks is free
every ticket Tom you know Tom Hanks the
Hollywood actor he is very upset that
you are not doing exactly what he tells
you to do and what the w-h-o tells you
to do by wearing the mask and he's not
afraid to tell you what he thinks I
don't get it
all right I simply do not get it it is
literally the least you can do and if
you want to if anybody wants to build up
an argument about dueling the least they
do I wouldn't trust them with a driver's
license I mean when you drive a car you
got to obey speed lot speed the speed
limits gotta use your turn signal you
got to avoid hitting pedestrians if you
can't do those three things then I get
it you shouldn't be driving a car if you
can't wear a mask and wash your hands so
distance I don't understand I got no
respect for you man I don't buy your
argument finally finally a Hollywood
celebrity is mouthing off on a political
issue about which he knows absolutely
nothing it's about time
frankly I've just been waiting for this
my whole life and that now I gotta tell
him a little upset because it means Tom
Hanks has no respect for us I put so
much of my self-esteem in the respect
that Tom Hanks has for me but this is it
why are they so up why are they so
focused on the masks where are the damn
masks that's what they keep saying and
they tell you it's just about science
very little evidence that the masks do
much at all you can read some of it on
the CDC website this is the reason that
the Surgeon General came out early and
said don't wear the masks the reason
Eric's wall bail came out early Eric
freaking Zwolle came out and said don't
wear the masks don't buy the masks yet
because they just don't especially the
masks that we're using these cloth masks
or bandanas they're there's very little
evidence that they're having much effect
it is a psychological and tool to
convince people that we're doing
something we're helping out and we're
really in it together and it's a
political symbol to show that you're
willing to do what the left tells you to
do and you're on the right side of this
social question even something as
apparently trivial is wearing a mask is
intended
to tip this political battle that we're
having one way or the other and there is
no way to look at the current debate
over the lockdown is anything but
political the ever since the so called
health experts came out and said that if
you protest for conservative causes
you're killing people with the virus and
if you protest for leftist causes you
are actually stopping the spread of the
virus which they actually said a few
weeks ago ever since then the public
health establishment has no credibility
and so we need to have an authentic
politics and actually have these debates
ourselves
[Music]
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoice a software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description